so you're you're kind of like batman or
something
i like dark defender and that
that makes the dark pastor not push so
hard
hey guys pete here i've got another
short dexter new blood video today about
some answers that the writer producer
scott reynolds offered up in some
interviews he gave about episode 9 which
he has the writing credit on i wasn't
planning on making another new blood
video before the finale but i was out of
the house all day yesterday and i
listened to a couple of podcasts he was
on and he gave some definitive answers
to some questions i've seen coming up in
the comments from you guys he talked
about the choice they made with ketamine
confirmed who sent angela the envelope
with the screws whether the bartender
was in one of kurt's cases and even
hannah came up so there were a lot of
big questions that were answered i'll
tell you everything i picked up right
after this quick spoiler warning if you
don't want to know the answers to the
questions i just mentioned then this
video won't be for you this is not my
speculation about these things it comes
directly from the writer's room on the
show and now you have been warned and
with that out of the way let's get into
it
i guess to get the one big question i
saw the most out of the way right up
front is why did the show link the bay
harbor butcher case to the ketamine
dexter uses in new blood he explained
why they decided to use ketamine in the
new show he was in a small town it was a
question of what he would have access to
but also michael c hall's band had this
song ketamine and they wanted to use it
in the show that all checks out and
seems fine but why then create this
connection that when angela went looking
she would discover things that pointed
her to the bay harbor butcher case
considering that everyone who watched
the original show knows that he didn't
use ketamine he used m99 the answer here
was not as satisfying he said the
research is from an aggregate website
with clues people have speculated about
over the years he also cited real life
cases where m99 and ketamine got mixed
up or was misidentified especially in
older bodies that were discovered years
later so the actual website she found
was nothing official and that is clear
when you look at it and the reason it
showed up in the search result was
because it was listing tranquilizers
like ketamine and m99 and that's why she
got the hit and at the end he added that
he hopes that we can live with it
because that's why they did it it's good
to know that they at least thought it
through and you can decide whether or
not you want to accept that normally
after every episode of new blood i
listen to the official wrap-up podcast
that scott reynolds hosts as soon as
that comes out he's been involved with
the show since the beginning and you can
tell he is dedicated to his job he loves
the character and is passionate about
making both the original show and new
blood he posts a lot of great behind the
scenes photos on twitter and instagram
and i'll put links to his accounts in
the description because you'll want to
give him a follow if you aren't doing
that on his podcast this week he
interviewed clancy brown and there were
a few interesting details that came out
he mentioned that the writing that was
by the camera that said you're already
dead was left there by a previous victim
and when he was talking to clancy brown
they made it sound like kurt was
legitimately proud of what he's done
whenever he reacted that way to harrison
and dexter asking about it i still feel
like him being that eager to take credit
for doing all of it alone seemed kind of
suspect but the actor made it sound like
it wasn't important the other thing they
talked about here and across all the
podcasts really was the importance of
dexter presenting what he does in the
best possible light to harrison he
compared the wiggles kill to the first
kill we see in episode 1 and how they
both have the kind of victim that no one
feels sorry for this is a choice that
dexter made and the show made itself
whenever it introduced us to him in the
pilot and they talked about how he was
struggling with the truth at first it
was just about whether to tell him
everything and then changing the details
in some of the situations like how he
told him he killed trinity because of
what he did to rita instead of how that
really happened so i guess pay attention
to whether harrison is getting the truth
or he's getting the story that dexter
wants him to hear
as far as direct answers scott was
interviewed on the fanatics podcast
which i'll link to in the description
that's actually co-hosted by david
magadoth who plays the role of teddy on
the show on there scott confirmed that
kurt did send the screws to angela and
he said that in the writer's room they
didn't even try to make that a mystery
or think that fans would interpret it
that way they wanted it to play like
kurt's last fu to dexter then the other
podcast that had a lot of questions and
answers was dissecting dexter which has
been around for a long time and i think
is rather popular on there we learned
that batista is actually remarried there
was a question about him wearing a
wedding ring in the scene with angela
with some fans speculating that it might
be the same one he had since he was
married to laguerta scott said that he
is remarried and that they actually
wrote a whole scene where he would be
sitting with his family at the dinner
table when angela called him but
production got in the way of that
happening and this isn't a hundred
percent clear if it was something that
would have happened earlier and then it
was just cut or if this is something
that's upcoming that angela will call
batista but he won't be in a room with
his family when that happens another
question that he was kind of surprised
that fans had was whether tess the
teacher and bartender who became
unwittingly involved in kurt's ritual
when he came into the tavern to dance
with her fans thought that they
recognized her in one of the cases and
that turned out to not be true he said
that he killed molly because she was a
threat and of course we know he went
after harrison for revenge but otherwise
they said that kurt would never go after
anyone from the town another question
that he was asked that i see a lot was
that angela seemed so obsessed with
dexter now that she's forgotten about
the missing girl cases that she was into
for so long he explained that the
writers actually think that she believes
that his dad killed iris and now she's
actually just more focused on the
problem at hand that this guy that she's
led into her life intimately who's been
a part of her life for over two years
might be a lot darker than she could
have ever imagined he also addressed the
theory that harrison could have killed
hannah before he left argentina he said
it was the exact opposite that she
really took good care of him so it was a
tragedy when she died and he had to
enter the foster care system harrison
had hurt people just like he claimed and
we saw him do in iron lake but he never
killed anyone before he got there
including hannah he also had a reaction
when he heard the term chekhov's gun
applied to the one that dexter gave to
harrison he didn't elaborate on why that
got him excited and the host of
dissecting dexter brought up the theory
that was out there that harrison might
kill himself with it and of course he
wouldn't confirm anything what it sounds
like and it's not a great surprise is
that that gun will be important in the
finale and you can think of multiple
ways that could play out the last thing
that i'll talk about and what i thought
was probably most interesting because it
was still speculative was talking about
how harrison actually felt when he was
watching the kill and the dismemberment
of kurt caldwell they said in the
writer's room they wanted the feeling to
be that you can't actually read how
harrison felt about it he was triggered
by the blood because he was reminded of
rita and that's similar to what happened
to dexter when he went into the hotel
room back in season one but they also
wanted to show that he's not as bad as
harry who vomited and ran away harrison
is in a place where he still loves his
dad and at this point he wants to please
him so he used the word inscrutable here
they wanted his reaction to be something
that you couldn't tell for sure what was
going on he said it's more about himself
than what dexter's doing but you know
they're intertwined so we'll see where
harrison goes from here so i think i can
leave it there there was some
interesting stuff so i wanted to pass it
on the links to all the podcasts and
everything else are in the description i
recommend that you listen to them for
yourself because there's a lot of stuff
that i left out let me know in the
comments how you're thinking about the
finale how you think it'll end or what
do you think there's only a couple days
left so please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon